hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the alexander
gambit which starts out with e4 e5
knight f3 knight c6 bishop c4 getting
into the italian game
and then bishop here to
five now last video i did was on the
leukemia gambit and that was after your
opponent played d3
we played the move f5 one of my favorite
openings if you haven't checked that out
i definitely recommend it but a lot of
people said hey d3 is not the most
common move what happens if they play
the move c3 which is by far the most
common move from white
this sets up the move d4 it sets up to
move b4
and so i said okay let's dig a little
bit deeper into what happens if they
play c3 and now we play f5 very
different
has a lot of the same principles but
this is the alexandria gamut so if you
watch that video or just curious maybe
you have not seen that video yet but
you're curious yeah i come across this
opening quite a bit they play c3 how do
we respond
this is gonna be going over what happens
if we play
f5 now the four variations that i will
be going over in this video the first
one is the accepted line they just take
here on f5 the next one is if they play
b4 pretty common in this opening to play
c3 and then b4
we're also going to be looking at if
they play the move d4 hey we're
attacking the center of the board
they're going to counter attack in this
here the board attacking our bishop here
on c5 which is a very dangerous piece as
it eyes down on this f2 square and then
the last variation we are going to look
at is castling on the king side so
without further ado let's go and jump
into the alexandria gambit
so the first variation is if they accept
our gambit here on f5 anytime that you
give up material you want to gain
something back for that pawn and so
we're going to be playing the move pawn
to d5 this opens up for a light square
bishop to get involved capture this pawn
here on f5 at some point get that
material back but also you can see we're
really controlling the center of the
board we have the only e pawn on the
board and also this pawn here on d5 is
gonna kick this bishop away or at least
it should i mean they're probably gonna
play bishop here to b5 probably their
best move kick it back here to b3 i
guess they could get pretty aggressive
if they wanted to counter attack in the
center uh d4 so we'll look at each of
those options and see how we would
continue bishop to b5 i think is the
most logical play for them and then
we're gonna play the move knight two e
seven it's a little awkward if we don't
because they do have the move knight
takes here on e5 and that just puts both
the knight and the bishop attacking this
knight here on a c6 and this knight is
pinned down it cannot move
because of the king here on e8 so i
think the best move is knight to e7 this
defends the knight here on c6 also
attacks the pawn here on f5 what this
does allow
white to do is come in and take this
pawn here on e5 if you're playing a game
but you have to be open to the idea of
giving up material
for a very strong attack and that's what
we're going to be doing in this opening
and especially in this variation so we
gave up one pawn here on f5 we're giving
up another pawn here on e5 we're gonna
go and castle on the king's head you can
see
white's just moving their same material
over and over they've moved their bishop
multiple times they've now moved their
knight multiple times and they don't
have any other material that's really
developed or can really get involved
into the game the bishop here on a c1 is
blocked by the pawn this knight here on
b1 really can't go anywhere knight to a3
at some point
neither of the rooks are involved into
the game and you can see from black
standpoint a lot of material is already
extremely
active here so we're attacking this pawn
right here we can gain some material
back we can obviously take this knight
here if we want to this knight on c6 is
no longer pinned from here i think we're
typically going to see pawn to d4 i'm
going over what i think is the most
logical moves the main lines that you'll
see if you don't see these it typically
is going to be a mistake i'm looking at
the best alternatives that white has and
so if you see something crazy just look
for
how black can really attack the opponent
okay so this is attacking our bishop
right here i think we're going to go and
take the knight here on
e5 they have a couple options they could
take our knight they could take our
bishop if they decide to go ahead and
take our bishop
then we're just gonna play knight takes
here on f5 if they castle now we can
attack the bishop bishop comes back here
that's completely fine if we come back
and say uh maybe they take our knight
instead okay now we just played bishop
takes here on uh f5 maybe castle on the
king side knight two g6 we're attacking
this pawn here on e5 uh black's gonna
have a pretty solid game from here
coming back to this position instead of
coming here to b5 the bishop could also
just retreat back to b3 and we're going
to push forward with e4 and this is
going to be a common theme you'll see
throughout
this opening here is pushing the pawn
here to e4 attacking this knight now the
knight's not gonna come here to e5
because then we can just easily take it
right here you can see a free piece so
instead they could say knight to
d4
they could also counter attack in the
center of the board with d4 so let's
take a look at both of those the first
one being knight to
d4
in this case we're just going to go and
take with our bishop after they take
ours we're going to go ahead and take
with our bishop here on f5
and we have a pretty good setup here you
can see that both sides are equal in
material they have double pawns here
in the center with no pawns to protect
on either the e file or the c file
black can still cast on either side of
the board so a lot of flexible options
here and so i think this is going to be
a really good spot for black if we come
back instead of playing knight to a d4
if they try to just counter attack in
the center of the board pawn to d4 we're
going to go and take material because if
they take we can take here and things
get pretty difficult for them like we're
attacking their rook they almost need to
play rook here to g1 uh because they
don't have any other threats this bishop
here on b3 it's being stopped by the
pawn here on d5 which is crucial because
if they try to get their queen involved
into the game
okay well it doesn't have any other
material to help so we can just play g6
and they can't just take here looking to
do anything else because we're just
going to take their rook here on
h1 check we have a queen so that's not
going to work they realize they have to
move their queen back then we just play
queen to e7 yes they could exchange
right here but at the end of the day
they're eventually going to have to play
rook to g1
and now we can come up here with e5 uh
putting a lot of pressure on our
opponents we have knight up to f3 as a
move we also have the move knight to d3
so a lot of threats that we have and we
can also just take this material here on
f5
get that pawn anytime we want to
all right so last thing we'll look at
for this variation is instead of coming
here to b5 or retreating back to b3 they
could also just counter attack in the
center of the board with d4 say hey if
you're going to take my bishop
i'm going to go ahead and take your
bishop as well hey we are definitely
going to take their bishop there's no
doubt about that if they don't play b5
or b3 we're definitely taking their
bishop if they take ours that's fine as
well we can now exchange our queens
they have to take with their king right
here now we can play bishop takes on f5
getting that material back here and now
let's say knight two d2 we castle on the
queen side their king has already moved
so it cannot castle it's going to be in
the center of the board here we're going
to be looking at knight 2 f6 get both of
our rooks in the center of the board we
should have a pretty good game from here
as well so that's what happens if they
decide to take
with the pawn early on with pawn takes
here f5
the next version we are going to look at
is the move pawn to
b4 says hey we're we want to attack this
bishop
and we know that you already have a
defender here with your pawn on e5 so
we're not ready to push forward here
with d4
but unfortunately this falls because if
they just play pawn to b4 we are
immediately
playing bishop takes here on f2
extremely strong move
if they take it's not good for them but
they almost have to take because if they
just play
king 2 f1
then we take with our pawn here on e4
attacking the knight here and what do
they really do from here the knight
doesn't have any good options it can't
come back here to
d1 or d2 it can't come back here to h2
if it comes here to g5 it's just going
to fall to our queen it can't come here
because that's protected by our knights
here so it just doesn't have a lot of
good options probably just take with the
king now but then we take with our pawn
and they're in a world of trouble we can
get our queen evolved into the game now
and their king is completely exposed so
they pretty much have to take
with their king here on f2 but then the
same thing we play pawn takes e4
attacking this knight right here where
does the knight go to
well first they may just decide to
exchange some material right here
because our threat of knight to f6
getting involved could get pretty
frustrating for them but knight comes
back to e1 they just don't have too many
safe squares and now we play queen 2 h4
so yes we did sacrifice a bishop here on
f2 but the king is gonna be exposed to
the rest of the game we're going to be
attacking it now we can play pawn d5
getting our light square bishop
involvement to the game we're just gonna
be putting so much pressure on our
opponent so if they play b4
uh i am all about it because i'm going
to be ready to attack for the rest of
the game don't have to worry too much if
they play this pawn to b4
now the best move they can play is d4 i
don't know how many people will actually
try this variation but it is very
difficult for black to find an advantage
so i think it's important as we go over
any chess opening to make sure you
understand
where the weaknesses are and i do think
that white has the upper hand if they
play correctly and that is
d4 now black still has a lot of
attacking lines and they do have to play
correctly we are going to first take
here on e4
attacking the knights i think they're
pretty much always going to
uh just take here on e5 they could also
take our bishop so we'll look at that
variation as well but knight takes here
on e5 makes a ton of sense to me we go
ahead and take with our own knights and
then they take our knight right here yes
they could take our bishop but that
would be a mistake because then we could
just take their bishop here with our
knight so i'm going to assume that
they're going to play correctly take our
knight right here then we're going to
play queen 2 e7 preparing to attack
that pawn now if they don't play knight
two e5 maybe they decide to go ahead and
take our bishop here on a c5 that's fine
we're gonna go ahead and take their
knight here on f3 if they take with
their queen great we're gonna play
knight two f6 we have to stop the threat
of queen down to f7 this would be
checkmate can't allow that to happen so
knight to f6 stopping that if they come
down and attack attack that knight
that's completely fine doesn't really
matter because if they play bishop takes
here okay we're just going to take with
our queen and we don't even care if they
come down in exchange uh that's
completely fine as well but all of these
variations uh i do think white comes out
with a a
pretty good game
setup i mean black's not in a terrible
spot by any means but all the other
variations i'm going over i do think
black has a slight advantage this is one
i do think white is able to
maintain their advantage so we'll come
back the last variation that we are
going to look at instead of playing pawn
to
d4 in the center of the board last
version is if they play castle on the
king side
now you've been paying attention the
rest of the video you probably know what
the next move and that is pawn takes
here on e4 now my hope is that if
someone
actually
plays this from white standpoint that
they actually feel like they can't
really move their knight anywhere that
maybe knight to e1 is really their only
option which would be a terrible move
moving the knight back blocking off the
rook here on f1 black should be able to
just completely overwhelm the opponent
because if they look at and say man
knight takes here on e5 well it's not
protected they can just go ahead and
take material right here that is true
but they do have the move queen to h5
this is pretty much forcing the move
knight to
g6
and so i i do think that they have ways
to get back into the game but some
players may just not play that knight to
e5 but if they do
we're actually not going to take this
knight now we hope that they feel like
we're going to but we're actually not
going to because of the setup i just
show you instead first we're going to
play the move pawn to
d5
attacking the bishop
now let's say they attack
our knight here on c6 we're gonna go and
take with our pawn here now if they come
down to you know queen two h5 we're
gonna play the move king to f8 you have
to be careful here you can't play g6
because they're going to fork our rook
here and then we play
king d7 they take our rook here on h8
like things just do not go well
for us so we have to be careful as far
as what we play
so we're just going to play the move
pawn to
c6
and then we should be in a good spot
after queen to h8 if they want to then
we just play king to
f8 but then we're going to be looking to
play knight to
f6 we can also take the bishop here on
c4 i think this is the way that black
wants to attack it does not have to
worry about too many threats
that white has right now you can still
see that this dark square bishop is
blocked in this knight here on b1 is
blocked in that's part of the reason
that we can start to attack our opponent
once they play c3 is it really boxes in
this knight here on b1
you really are only looking at knight to
a3 that's ever going to get this night
involved into the game and since the
nightstand moving the rook here on a1
is not going to be involved in the game
as well so that is the alexandria gambit
so i know a lot of people they got
excited once they saw the leukemia gamut
and they said hey i love the idea of
playing this f5 but what happens if our
our opponent plays the move c3 well
hopefully this video gives you an idea
of how you can attack it i think black
has a really really good game plan uh if
you are playing from white's standpoint
i do think the best option is to play
that move pawn to
d4 but hopefully this builds out your
repertoire of moves that you can play in
the italian gioco piano
this position right here
you know if they play c3 or d3 you
should now be locked and loaded so again
thanks so much for watching this video
if you have a video recommendation this
video i just made was a recommendation
from someone on my last video so if
there's something you want me to make
feel free to let me know you can email
me you can leave a note in the comments
below either those will definitely get
to me but thank you guys so much for
watching i'll see you guys in the next
video
you